l'argentine premier état
latino-américain à déployer spoutnik
vais sur son territoire buenos aires s
accorde sa confiance au vaccin russe
alors qu'en termes d'infection il est le
pays le plus touché du continent après
le brésil et la colombie
une campagne de vaccination dans
laquelle le personnel de santé et
prioritaires au sein d'une population de
45 millions d'habitants
les autorités ont enregistré plus d'un
million et demi de cas positifs depuis
le début de la pandémie
après le mexique le costa rica le chili
l'argentine est désormais le quatrième
état d'amérique latine a lancé sa
campagne de vaccination contre le
coronavirus les argentins attendent
beaucoup de ce vaccin qu'elle montera
pas été grâce à notre nation notre pays
d'être capable de voir ce jour est le
début de la phase de vaccination
on peut vraiment en être fier tous les
argentins peuvent être fiers et
continuer à travailler ensemble pour
protéger la population avec ce vaccin
[Applaudissements]
cela nous rassure un peu de penser que
c'est le début de la fin de cette
situation vraiment étrange et nous
attendions ça depuis tellement longtemps
de juste essayé de franchir une première
étape pour en finir avec ce virus
je suis vraiment très fier
nous leur côté les premiers biélorusses
ont reçu une injection de spoutnik v
après des essais cliniques menés par les
autorités locales après l'argentine la
biélorussie devient ainsi le deuxième
pays est homologué le vaccin russe le
ministre de la santé via le russe a
indiqué que minsk était sur le point de
lancer sa propre production du remède
par des sociétés pharmaceutiques locales
il est très important de souligner que
nous avons reçu un vaccin prêt à être
utilisé qui a subi des tests cliniques
et qui a été homologué comme les airs il
est tout aussi important que dans la
coopération avec nos partenaires russes
nous travaillons actuellement dans le
cadre de la dernière phase de production
locale du vaccin spoutnik v par nos
sociétés pharmaceutiques non moscou la
russie a signé des accords avec
plusieurs pays d'amérique latine et
d'asie pour livrer des doses du vaccin
ces derniers jours des lots de spoutnik
vais en notamment été réceptionnés en
hongrie